[Music]
hello everyone welcome to
talk to you over a series
of videos of about 5 to 7 minutes
each we will present the
main bricks used for the
migration of a client with a stack lamp
to the cloud
my name is fortunately Korean and I
am an engineer within the entity
professional services organization of
google there in this episode we will migrate
the mysql database of the
unstable fantastic knitting which has grown
faster than the only
IT infrastructure on  which she started
the needs and priorities of
the company are to have a
highly available database and the
reduction of administrative tasks
while limiting the impact of this
migration
a first approach called lift a
shift is simply  the installation
of mysql on a virtual machine
google captain jean a configuration
similar to the existing configuration
then to migrate the data the
scalabi  ity is not yet addressed
even if on google cloud we can
easily allocate more resources to
virtual machines on the other hand
the data administrator will always have as
much work we will not
use this approach but if you
want more details consult this
article on the google cloud site in the
web solution part of the apps website you
will find the link to the article in the
description of the video
the second approach always lifts a
shift but which has introduced a little more
of the platform's answer is to
take advantage  from the fully
managed mysql cloud sql offer the migration steps
will be similar to the first approach
with the addition of simplified
management both for
installation migration is later
necessary database server updates
google doesn't do
the database administration
instead of the fantastic knitting debate
but makes it a whole lot easier
you wonder  maybe
it's clear skull cloud sql and
fully managed database services
that makes it easy to set up
maintain management
and administration of your
postgressql and mysql relational databases in
the google cloud
with uptime  greater than 99
for 95% it's a
scalable performance solution that offers
up to 10 terabytes the
perfect storage space for fantasy knitting needs
and now on to the demo we'll
follow five steps to create a copy
a replica  to the sql cloud with the
minimum of downtime
then promote it at new year
pass tapine for the demo we can
consider that the configuration of the
current database is in accordance
with the credit which for replication to
claude sql on to mysql  version 5 6 or 5 7
the active binary log and didier to
activate and
mysql account with replication rights this book
is of course the database to be migrated  é
accessible from the gct via an external ip v4
steps for creating the
sql cloud replica will be done by
following this guide to him not so you
will find the reference in the
description of the video
first time creating the
sql cloud replica of  the local database
requiring cloud storage baquette for
temporary data storage
export we will create it on the command line
with cloud dear our dear fan integrated with
the google cloud console with
the utility I like this style second
step from a machine  with access to the
source database and the cloud sdk
installed we first create a copy of
data with the mysql utility of amp
account then entrust to the
gcs bucket with the useful gs command third
step creation of the instance  cloud sql
for the replica
the fantastic knitting database
and the cloud sql instance
that hosts it will be created using the
icloud beta command is what it
is listed
my my  from the creation of the database we
also take the data from the
cloud storage bucket the first
command creates the link to the
source database and the second the
replica the speed of replication between
cloud storage and cloud sql and from 25 to 50
gigabytes not their fourth step you
must configure the
local database to accept connections from
the replica and this less than 30
minutes after the creation of the latter you
must also check the configuration of the
fail resources to accept
connections from the replica for  find
the ip address of the replica we can use
the command dit claude sql insurance
describe 5th optional step is to
restrict the access of the
mysql replication user on the
source database to only the ip and of the replica
it is  a good security practice 6th
step to finalize the configuration of the
replica you must create a user
with the cloud utility or the
google cloud web console
you must check  ier than the range of
ip addresses authorized to access the replica
suddenly the ips of the client applications where
you have to use other methods such
as proxies 7th step check the
replication status in the google
cloud console on the cloud page  sql in
chandolin replicate information panel
should be zero or tend
to zero 8th step
we can clean up the east bin
gcs the files and east bin can
be deleted with
jesuit command he was wandering step 3 bring
their  fruits' web directly to the
replica step 4 promote the replica to
as an independent database with
the cloud command sql instance
promote replica to check the
result we can use the
google cloud console or the cloud command sql
instance describe the owners
check its  database application ipad
and master in the snake
step 5 you can now
restart your applications and
configure them to point to the instance  e
cloud sql
we have seen how to replace a
mysql instance the cal with tell them that
our company the fantastic knitting
will now be able to use its
usual database while taking advantage of
the fully managed service on google
cloud an improvement in this
architecture will be the use  in
haproxy upstream
local mysql database or cloud sql
using haproxy instance you create an
access point which you can point
to the initial database
later you can point it to
the replica  samrée configure clients
during migration other
alternatives are possible but are
not necessarily suitable for our company
such as this panel or
nosql databases
they could be viable solutions
if we need to replicate
data across  multiple regions
but they require a
significant change in the application which is
not justified for the quarter  er to close
our episode on databases
take a look at the description of
this video you will find
additional resources to
deepen what you saw
today
thank you for listening and see you soon
[Music]